en el último vídeo hablamos de los
campos vectoriales en tres dimensiones y
terminamos digamos con un ejemplo que
era la función identidad donde teníamos
de entrada x y z y teníamos como vector
salida también x y z y aquí quisiera
digamos entrar en un ejemplo un poquito
más complicado así que vamos a quitar
este campo vectorial y en este ejemplo
la componente x de la salida será de x
zeta vamos a poner que por z la
componente de la salida será x por zeta
y la componente zeta de nuestra salida
será x por llega así que vamos a mostrar
este campo vectorial para poder tener
una mejor intuición de cómo es que se
comporta esta función y poder ver cómo
se relaciona con los vectores que vemos
así que aquí tenemos un montón de
vectores que digamos están apuntando
desde el origen verdad algunos apuntan
hacia el origen y en realidad podríamos
preguntarnos cómo poder entender este
campo vectorial en términos de la misma
función verdad y un buen inicio es hacer
0 algunas de las componentes de la
salida en este caso voy a elegir la
tercera componente qué
es x porque verdad y entonces vamos a
tratar de entender que debería ser así
que la componente zeta representa
digamos que tanto apunta el vector hacia
arriba o hacia abajo en el eje z y aquí
tenemos el plano xy así que vamos a
marcar el eje z digamos es el eje que
está apuntando hacia nuestra cara verdad
aquí tenemos el eje x el eje i y los
valores de xy llevan a determinar
completamente la componente z así que
vamos a irnos de este lado por aquí
vamos a dibujar un pequeño plano xy para
tener cierta referencia y este es
digamos mi valor x mi valor y ahora
quiero entender digamos el significado
del término x porque así que cuando
ambos términos es decir cuando xy que
son positivos el producto es positivo
cuando ambos son negativos también el
producto es positivo si x es negativo y
es positivo el producto es negativo y
finalmente si x es positivo y es
negativo el producto también es negativo
así que esto significa en términos de
nuestro campo vectorial que cuando
estamos en el primer cuadrante
los vectores tienden a apuntar hacia
arriba en la dirección z verdad lo mismo
ocurre en el tercer cuadrante pero en
los otros dos deberían estar apuntando
hacia abajo así que vamos a enfocarnos
primero en el primer cuadrante y vamos a
tratar de ver qué es lo que está
ocurriendo en general todos apuntan
hacia arriba verdad tienen una
componente zeta positiva y esto va de
acuerdo con lo que estábamos diciendo
hace unos momentos mientras que por
ejemplo por acá que corresponde al
cuarto cuadrante en el plano x la
componente zeta de cada vector tiende a
ir tiende a ir hacia abajo y están
haciendo quizás otras cosas en términos
de xy de verdad no sólo tienen una
componente zeta pero aquí sólo nos
estamos fijando en digamos la dirección
hacia arriba y hacia abajo así que si
nos fijamos en el tercer cuadrante por
ejemplo tienden a apuntar hacia arriba y
eso corresponde con el hecho de que x x
ye será positivo y debido a que elegí
digamos una función que es más o menos
simétrica puedes imaginarte que podemos
hacer este argumento cuando analizamos
la componente ya que tenemos aquí verdad
o cuando analizamos la componente x en
términos de jay-z y de hecho se va a ver
similar serán argumentos muy parecidos
para entender cuando la componente x de
nuestro vector tiende a ser positiva
como por ejemplo aquí verdad o cuando
resulta ser negativa y lo mismo podemos
decir de la componente de verdad
podríamos ver cuando resulta ser
positiva o cuando tiende a ser negativa
es verdad y en general digamos esta es
una imagen muy complicada de analizar
verdad pero si nos vamos digamos pedazo
por pedazo al menos podemos tener una
muy buena intuición de qué es lo que
está ocurriendo y justo como en el caso
de los campos vectoriales de dos
dimensiones digamos algo muy bonito que
podemos hacer aquí es imaginar que esto
representa un fluído verdad y podríamos
imaginar que quizás es aire que está
alrededor de ti que está fluyendo
digamos hacia el origen por ejemplo de
este lado quizás está fluyendo hacia
otro lado lejos del origen por acá y
quizás está rotando por este lado y más
adelante cuando sigamos en este curso de
cálculo multivariable aprenderemos que
hay varias formas en la que podemos
estudiar esta función en sí misma verdad
solo usando estas variables verdad y
cuando tenemos alguna intuición de cómo
es que ese fluido se comporta entonces
podemos tener un entendimiento de la
función incluso si es una función muy
complicada y por ejemplo si es muy
complicada de dibujar podríamos utilizar
un software gráfico para analizarlo
verdad o bueno podremos usar otro tipo
de herramientas para obtener muchos más
resultados un poco más poderosos y este
tipo de cosas aparecen en la física todo
el tiempo porque en realidad estamos
pensando en un espacio de tres
dimensiones que bueno no precisamente
tiene que ser un flujo de algún líquido
o algo del aire de verdad podría ser un
campo de fuerzas como un campo eléctrico
verdad o puede ser un campo
gravitacional donde cada vector nos dice
digamos la forma en la que cada
partícula tiende a ser empujada y
continuaremos con más cálculo de varias
variables veremos muchos más ejemplos
pero al menos espero que esto te haya
dado una buena intuición de cómo podemos
analizar paso por paso digamos a alguna
función particular que pueda tener una
expresión
muy complicada